wir haben auch die deutschen gefragt
welche eigenschaften schreiben sie
eigentlich den beiden kanzlerkandidaten
zu wie sind die so für sie haben die
humor kann man mit denen lachen sind die
kompetenz sind sie glaubwürdig das haben
wir 1000 deutsche befragt 15
eigenschaften haben wir zur auswahl
gegeben und da gab es die sächsin ganz
ehrlich überraschende ergebnisse und der
ein oder andere wird sich da vielleicht
auch mal auf die zunge beißen und denken
oh weia wie soll ich da wieder rauskommt
schauen wir uns mal die ergebnisse an
über 1000 menschen haben wir gefragt
welche eigenschaften schreiben sie
eigentlich den kanzlerkandidaten am
meisten zu werfen wir als erstes kein
und paul mal hier ein blick auf armin
laschet 15 eigenschaften waren zur
auswahl und das sind die top five und er
das geht echt in die magengrube die
erste eigenschaft die die deutsche nord
angekreuzt haben 32,4 prozent ist
langweilig eine eigenschaft paul jetzt
mit diesen wahlkampf beobachtet da gab
es ups und downs man kann sein aber
langweilig war das ja bisher eigentlich
nicht langweilig war es ganz sicher
nicht was in der cdu bei der csu
passiert ist auch die debatten die es
gegeben hat man muss insgesamt sagen
vielleicht ist langweilig gar nicht das
schlechteste wenn wir uns jetzt mal auf
den punkt bringen will denn das bedeutet
ja auch keine skandale keine
überraschung durchschnittlich langweilig
das ist sozusagen das was man dann was
dann dort hängen bleibt aber es ist
etwas natürlich weiß ich wie du siehst
ganz ehrlich das ist ein vernichtendes
urteil
wenn du so sehr im rampenlicht steht
wenn du der unions kanzlerkandidaten ist
wenn du überall plakatiert bist und nach
aber das ist ja der unterschied ist so
viel plakatiert das ist ja der wahlkampf
der cdu die darauf gesetzt haben dass
deutschland nicht häufig um für dich
weil er möglicherweise als so langweilig
gilt aber wenn du so im rampenlicht
steht wenn du
nrw-ministerpräsident bist wenn du es
jetzt halt rocken muss in den
bundestagswahlkampf wenn du auch nicht
mehr viel zeit hast und dann sagt ihr
die mehrheit der deutschen 32,4 prozent
sagen du bist langweilig die haben gar
keine lust den erkennst du ja das ist
ein total vernichtendes urteil
also ich finde noch einmal das
langweilig auf den ersten blick
vernichten ist aber wenn man auf den
zweiten blick schaut dass es etwas sein
kann
der deutsche sei das anderen kanzlerin
moment kann die kanzlerin würde ich auch
eher als langweilig ist klein aber die
ist ja für viele deutsche macht die
nicht spannende ist also sie ist so
langweilige person am ende auch die
meisten deutschen wollen sich mit angela
merkel doch mal treffen in abend erst
nach dem mittagessen die nähe
kennenlernen und hier ganz offenbar ist
das bei armin laschet nicht der fall das
ist schon das interpretiere ich dem
dieses langweilig rhein main sind
knallhart das zeugnis der durch man muss
aber sagen als er mir eben auch regina
sagen hören also mit dem einen trinken
gehen das würde ich schon und wir
schauen auf die weiteren eigenschaften
die ami laschet ihr zugeschrieben werden
denn immerhin humorvoll ist dabei also
ein werthaltig nicht nur eingeschätzt
bei ihm theaterreise schön weil er
gemacht hat im freundlicherweise ja das
zeug nicht für humor paul nein aber wenn
man sich eine rheinische frohnatur so zu
sagen okay achten karneval aller dinge
die man eigentlich mit armin laschet
verbunden hat schon einmal hier
gemeinsam auf dem platz zwei abgehoben
das ist der platz 2 also dass diese
eigenschaften die deutschen armin
laschet ist du darauf was positives ist
das finde ich das bin ich erwähne
verwunderlich muss ich sagen denn wenn
man jetzt mal zurückschauen in den
letzten jahren da gab es keine skandale
die ihnen besonders abgehoben bezeichnet
haben möglicherweise fällt da eben mit
in den topf derjenigen der skandale der
union die ist dann in den vorwochen vor
monaten gegeben hat auch wenn er damit
nichts zu tun hatte aber es gab viele
diskussionen um mass kraft ist um
nebentätigkeiten in der union vielleicht
ist das sozusagen der grund dafür dass
auch der spitzenkandidat in die richtung
beschrieben würden wir schauen einmal
zum vergleich auf olaf scholz wie schaut
es bei dem eigentlich aus welche
eigenschaften schreiben die deutschen
ihm zu und da kommt ganz vorne erfahren
gut kein wunder also wenn man nach den
jahren in der politik nicht als erfahren
geld wäre auch schlecht oder also das
sind natürlich schon bessere werte auch
hier vor olaf scholz das muss man ganz
ehrlich sagen also das sind natürlich
erstmal eigenschaften die als positiv
gelten in so einem politiker alphatieren
erfahren 33 prozent der deutschen sagen
dass kompetent 29,1 prozent und trotzdem
ist das ja eine selbstverständlichkeit
mensch der mann
bundesfinanzminister war hamburgs erster
bürgermeister
vizekanzler und so weiter und so fort
ist seit über 20 jahren dabei wenn du da
nicht erfahren bis als kompetent gilt
also das sind die ab basics die er
erzielt und bei und möglicherweise kein
wurde eben bislang zu wenig zum beispiel
über das gesprochen was in hamburg
passiert ist bei den g20-protesten
wirecard kam ex alles zu schwierig die
dinge auf den auf den punkt zu bringen
oder runter zu brechen viele leute sagen
aber so richtig ist im olaf scholz noch
nicht in die mangel genommen worden in
der tat wir werden das heute tun mit
hilfe der zuschauer mit hilfe der
zuschauer fragen wir wollen dass olaf
scholz sehe ich heute festlich und auch
nicht damit durchkommt du hast es schon
vorhin gesagt mit so einem wahlkampf wo
er eigentlich nichts machen muss wo er
einfach nur liegen bleiben muss die
anderen machen schon die fehler das wird
ja heute nicht passieren aussetzen für
das kanzleramt wird nicht reichen heute
muss er hier mehr tun eben mit ihrer
hilfe mit den fragen der zuschauer das
sind einfach noch mal ein bisschen hier
spazieren gehen humorvoll das haben
jetzt ein bisschen aufgeschlüsselt aber
das ist platz 14 es ist der vorletzte
platz die deutschen glauben also mit
unna potsdam nichts also ich wundere
mich über die 80 7 prozent
aber ehrlich gesagt keine eigenschaft
die ihn kanzler unbedingt haben mussten
also der muss sich permanent die
deutschen zum lachen bringen mal ein
bisschen spaß man ein bisschen lachen in
der politik finde ich nicht verkehrt
aber ob das eine zwingende eigenschaft
wenn kanzler ist das würde ich an der
stelle durch ja in zweifel ziehen aber
bodenständig das halt auch ein kanzler
schon sein und das war ja bei armin
laschet das gegenteil war der fall da
stand abgehoben auf dem zweiten drittel
waren wir bei olaf scholz es
bodenständig also offenbar scheint es
ihnen zu gelingen ganz nah beim fall zu
sein der eine sache darf man nicht
vergessen glaube ich wir erinnern uns an
einem interview vor ein paar monaten wo
es darum ging ob olaf scholz eigentlich
die preise kennt ja wir haben sie immer
geführt ich glaube dass ich war das und
wir haben ihm verschiedene weise
serviert kaffee milch und so weiter
bruder hatte keine ahnung und dann vor
allem besonders bezeichnet er wusste
nicht mal was der liter sprit kostet
geil ja wir waren das wird noch mal mit
ihm olaf scholz ein bisschen später ganz
interessant finde ich hier auf der tafel
patriotisch 6,5 prozent der deutschen
nur halten olaf scholz für patriotisch
das heißt das ist schon interessanter
wert und der wert bei armin laschet war
ja nicht besser hier schneidet er
also in der st der wert bei dem die
deutschen am wenigsten sagen jaja da
stimme ich zu dass ist eine eigenschaft
die ich diesen kandidaten zu schreiben
warum eigentlich nicht also mich würde
das schon heute abend die frage
interessiert ist das überhaupt in
ordnung den kanzler in deutschland zu
haben der ja gar nicht als patriot auch
ein stück weit geht es bei uns
vielleicht aber auch paul irgendwie
negativ besetzt dieses wort patriotisch
zu sein möglicherweise ich habe auch
keine schnelle analyse dafür warum das
so ist aber ich finde es erstaunlich
gerade über einen kanzlerkandidaten der
union wo sozusagen grundsätzlich
eigentlich
vaterlandsliebe patriotismus und so
weiter immer eine große rolle gespielt
hat als bei der sozialdemokratie als bei
der spd dass der wert sogar noch ein
bisschen schlechter ist als der von olaf
von olaf scholz der bei 6 prozent lag
ist er zum 5 das finde ich schon sehr
überraschend gleichzeitig sehen wir hier
bei aml asche typisch deutsch das ist
der dritte platz also typisch täuscht
das heißt ja auch eigentlich
widerspricht das so ein bisschen diesem
abgehoben denn er ist typisch deutsch
oder ist es etwa typisch deutsche
abgehoben zu sein fragten sie das ist
schon ich meine typisch deutsch kann man
sagen bei armin laschet wohnt in einem
reihenhaus
seine seine frau wurden doch in aachen
buchhändlerin da sind eigentlich so
dinge wo man sagt ja das ist irgendwie
eine typisch deutsche familie ja typisch
deutsch aber auch dem werden wir heute
ein bisschen auf den zahn fühlen was ist
das eigentlich ist das bulette ist das
volksmusik oder betrifft das eben solche
eigenschaften wie fleißig zu sein wie
bodenständig zu sein und so weiter und
auch da wollen wir heute bei beiden
kandidaten mal ein bisschen nachfühlen
ich schaue mir nochmal einmal zuletzt
auf folgende grafik die finde ich sehr
sagt auch sehr sehr viel aus die frage
war wem vertrauen sie mehr und schaut
euch dort mal den vorsprung an olaf
scholz mit 40,1 und armin laschet mit
11,8 prozent aber auch interessant
interessant diese zahl beiden
gleichermaßen also 38,7 prozent sagen
weil ich da beiden so eine katastrophale
werte patricia ich glaube in der
geschichte der unions kanzlerkandidaten
hat keiner solche werte gehabt in dieser
brutalität muss man ja sagen denn es
sind nur noch sechs wochen bis zur wahl
das wird man auch nicht mehr in der
größe drehen können da sagt man adenauer
haus ja ja es kommt jetzt nicht so sehr
auf die persönlichen werte am ende ist
es ja so dass immer noch mehr leute cdu
wählen wollen und dass vor allem die cdu
als regierungspartei mehr gewollt ist
dass da ein bisschen die ausrede dass
solche werte dann nicht so zählen er
ganz wichtige frage für heute abend kann
man sowas drehen kann laschet aus dem
ultimativen tief rauskommen kann sich
das wieder drehen im zuge zb dieser
kanzler nacht heute bei bild live
[Musik]